Darby Allen he's pretty tight with bam
he came over and he's skating the ramp a
couple days ago he was like hey man I
lost touch with bam I don't know a
number for him I don't anything you know
want bam to see my ramp dude can you
text him this clip and uh Darby let me
know that bam got back to him and Bam
asked was steo talking about
me and Derby said no he wasn't he just
wants you Toc his ramp the craziest part
of why I brought up Darby Allen is that
he told me Bam's got his alcohol monitor
bracelet off I was shocked he's got it
off and he isn't exact that's crazy I
even said I bet my sobriety when that
bracelet comes off he's right back to
where he left off and when I found that
out I was like wow things are changing